it's so easy to have our heads down
on youtube that we don't actually come
up to see what trends are happening in
marketing in general and
how do we become the person that's able
to leverage
these trends i am so excited for you to
hear today's
featured conversation with sean cannell
and eric sue
where you're going to hear a dynamic
entrepreneur who really has the pulse on
modern marketing my name is heather
torres and you are listening to the
think marketing show the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
with youtube
and turn that influence into a high
profit and
high impact online business if you're
new to the podcast
welcome make sure you subscribe because
every single tuesday we are dropping a
brand new
fire episode just for you you can
subscribe wherever you're listening to
this content on
and stick around to the end because i'm
going to share with you
a class that i think is the next step
for you
if you have not figured out how to crush
it on youtube
yet let's jump into today's featured
conversation
all about the trends of marketing
welcome back to the think marketing
podcast i'm so fired up for this episode
because we're going to be talking about
marketing trends for 2021 as well as
how you can level up this year and get
more impact not just in your business
but also in your life because i've got
eric sue the author
of leveling up eric how's it going good
to be here sean super happy
super super great to see you healthy
we're both healthy so no complaints
right so
for sure man grateful for you and uh
love that you do so many cool things you
run an incredible agency
you've got just an epic podcast a couple
different podcasts you got different
things going on
and you so you have your pulse majorly
on what's happening
in marketing as the host of marketing
school
and so man with 2020 being such an
absolutely insane year
and a lot of people wondering what
should my plan be how should i position
how should i pivot
what should i be paying attention to
what are some of the marketing trends
that you think we should be paying
attention to in 2021
i'll tell you one thing i'm taking my
phone out right here but um
you know do you have a clubhouse account
man i've been invited a couple times and
i've been so busy with youtube but
i've i've heard so much about it and i
need to get jump on that
it's becoming a pretty big thing so
andreessen horowitz which is a big vc
firm to back them
and um clubhouse is basically we can
start a room and just
make whatever topic and then people just
join and we can be nerding out like this
and then people be joining in maybe you
can invite people in
to have a conversation it's almost like
having off the cuff webinars
um so what's interesting is i was i did
my first
room yesterday with a couple friends you
know um a couple other entrepreneurs and
um we had like 20 30 people join right
and we don't have any audience on there
yet
but what's fascinating is we checked
some other rooms and it was like
how to prepare for 2021 or something you
got 1700 people and they're just hanging
out
that's like a big webinar in there right
so my point is
clubhouse i think is going to be a big
deal um twitter actually came out with
it
it looks very similar it's called
twitter spaces and all this centers
around
audio right you see spotify buying up
all these podcast companies them making
analytics better
um so i think audio is kind of the meta
trend and then you have these um you
know in
these little these apps that you can use
like twitter spaces or clubhouse
that's so interesting too because i also
i uh
just joined a mastermind with a couple
friends that's kind of like peer-led
and they're like how do you want to
communicate voxer and so they got me on
voxer
i got the voxer premium i started seeing
that there was all this action going on
voxer and audio is kind of the angle of
voxer as well yeah
yeah funny story voxers was actually a
client of single grains uh you know
back back in the day but yeah i think
voxer is a great example i think
what russell brunson's mastermind is a
good example it does a good job with
using voxer
um it's just it's personal and it's easy
right i think people in the room
yesterday were just saying like
it's a lot we can do it off the cuff we
can be sitting on our bed or whatever it
doesn't we don't have to prepare for
video like this not that there's
anything wrong with video
yeah so powerful what's the next trend
uh
a lot of seos are talking about gpt-3 i
think
i'm a little um skeptical about it
because
um in one sense because when marketers
get their hands on something they tend
to pollute it
and gpg3 is basically uh leveraging the
power of ai to create
copy at scale right so you can create
headlines at scale and all that type of
stuff there's
uh there's a tool called copy.ai and
there's another one called copysmith.ai
and they're all building very similar
tools right um but
if it saves time in terms of coming up
with captions for instagram or headlines
for youtube
um i'm all for it right i'm just hoping
that it doesn't bring everyone to
to the same level um it just raises the
bar to the next level everyone's there
so i'm hoping it's not the next version
of article spinning 2.0 which
is how people used to spam the internet
um back in the old seo days
man so good number three number three
is using mergers and acquisitions as
a marketing channel as a growth channel
right so as an example
single reign is an agency i bought it
was a failing agency
the work we were doing was no longer
working and i bought the company for two
dollars out of pocket
right and i negotiated the rest was
basically through um you know it was
seller finance and i had a contingency
where if the company failed i would owe
nothing
little did i know at that time i was
doing a version of mergers and
acquisitions
but what i was actually acquiring was i
was acquiring a website that had some
good domain authority
um i had you know great employees on the
team and we had a base to build off of
right so one plus one equals four
um and so the way i looked at it was um
if
i could if i could you know take the
talent and then take the website and
grow it
um it's it's we're gonna have a lot of
leverage right so basically
what we're able to do with that will say
okay you know once we once we're able to
turn the company around
let's take that cash flow and go invest
in other stuff which is largely what
we've been able to do
um that's one example another example
would be um i'm actually trying
i was trying to buy this seo company for
a couple million dollars
and um they had a customer base okay
they also had great software that is a
site with great domain authority
um and they also had a great team a
great cto that we can plug in
and we we thought of it as oh we can
plug that team in with clickflow which
is our software
we can plug the the customers into
clickflow as well
and then we could take the website and
then maybe we can build affiliate
content if we want and we're gonna have
all these other revenue streams right
um and the great news about mna is it's
not super complicated
um you can basically let's say instead
of paying let's say that
the sale price of a company is two
million dollars you can basically put 10
down in america 200 000 right and the
rest can be financed by
the sba and not enough people are taking
advantage of this and i think
looking at this from a marketing
perspective a growth perspective
um i don't you don't need to think that
you need to have a lot of money to do
this you don't
full and we're thinking a lot about that
at think uh media because we also
realize we've built
influence so how could we also then
potentially strategically
acquire something and use our influence
to growth hack it you know because we
already could point a lot of attention
there
and um really really cool strategy what
is your take
on the state of content marketing as far
as trends
going into the idea of not just 2021 but
the feeling that of course more people
are in the game than ever before there's
more crowds than ever before
and as a massive content creator
yourself as a business owner
as a leader as one that is in the
day-to-day operations
um what is kind of your approach for
winning as a content creator and
uh for the trends you see i think the
biggest thing you said was at the very
end i think
in the beginning maybe i don't know or
not in the beginning but couple years
ago i thought i had to be in the day to
day
i think the key thing is um even you're
a creator as well i think it's
the key for us as leaders is to get out
of the day-to-day and do the highest
leverage activity which is actually
creating content or doing deals
um and i i got this insight um i think
it's always in the back of my mind it's
like yeah i should probably just create
more content but
i was doing a podcast interview with uh
this guy named anthony pompliano
and he's got great audiences kind of
across the board twitter youtube podcast
and all that
and i was like so what do you do all day
he's like all i do is i create content
because um
you know i one of my jobs is invest in
companies it helps with deal flow i meet
amazing people
and uh you know it helps me get leverage
and so
i'm like wow yeah that should be the
only thing that i focus on um besides
doing deals so
the key thing was for me um was hiring
whether it's gm's or ceos for the the
businesses and running a day-to-day
well i i sit um at a strategic level and
kind of jump in here and there where
they need help
super super smart that's a high level of
thinking which really kind of teased us
up
into your new book called leveling up
and of course we'll link it up in the
show notes
and the description and everywhere you
got to pick up a copy of
this book um give us kind of the 30 000
foot level of
the book first and i want to ask you
about a couple of the strategies you
recommend because i know these are going
to help us grow our businesses
this year but what's the vision behind
leveling up
yeah i think the whole idea is you know
when we play games
did you play any games growing up oh
yeah i mean i i
and now i have a son that's a couple
months old and so i haven't been but i
just finished final fantasy
7 remake red dead redemption 2.
i've been crushing ghost of cinema
and then you go back street fighter
mortal kombat but final fantasy is a
great example when i think of leveling
up
yeah and how did you feel when you're
playing those games oh
i felt amazing yeah so i mean
the key thing here is you you feel
amazing i mean it brings you back to for
me when i think about my childhood it
makes me think like a child right and i
think that's one of the key things i
have in the book is
you know when you think like a child you
think like a beginner and that keeps you
curious it keeps you wanting to
grow more right so i think a lot of
stuff around gaming
if you reframe real life into a game it
becomes much easier and it just becomes
fun and so when i wake up every day and
by the way i think business is the
ultimate game
i just have so much fun i've recaptured
that same feeling that i had growing up
so
whether you play games or not you can
just say you might say eric i don't
resonate with you i didn't play games
well if you played sports or if you're
into sports
same deal sports is a game and you learn
a lot of the stuff that you learn
um from you know playing video games or
sports vice versa
it's the same deal you just got to look
at life as a game and it just becomes
better more fun man i love that and
you're absolutely right
uh life i think about you know i'm a
runner so i think about hitting
uh like my next personal best my next
personal record on
a certain distance like a half marathon
or in business you hit
a growth target an amount of leads
capture target a profit a revenue
all kinds of different targets well
there's so many amazing chapters and
topics because you give us these
levers for leveling up but i wanted to
just ask you about a couple of them that
we could apply
one of them level six is the apprentice
mentality what does that mean
yeah the apprentice mentality is
basically
approaching everything from a growth
mindset right or an apprentice mindset
you can call it a beginner's mindset as
well whatever you want to call it
i think it's once once you start to
think you're an expert once you start to
think you're really good
you start to decay very quickly you
start to become arrogant and you start
to become clouded with all these
you know random thoughts right that do
not help but
when i think about it like even when i'm
having conversations with with you like
this right now i i'm very much still
learning
and i'm approaching it with you know i'm
very much a
a naive person that's just trying to get
better right
when i approach it from that perspective
and i'm not coming off like a from a you
know
know-it-all cocky perspective i just
find that i build better relationships i
find that i'm much more open to things
and that in turn helps me compound my
knowledge
i think when you close yourself off like
an expert you start to i guess
decompound your interest yeah that's so
good and humility right i mean pride
comes before the fall so kind of to stay
stu stay a student stay humble and does
this include
even actually maybe finding different
models and different apprentices
in life i think about simon sinek who
wrote talks about you know worthy rivals
and that you know comparison will kill
our joy
right and potentially discourage us but
it is good to have worthy rivals and i
like to look
with respect for competitors and be
aware of what's happening in the spot
like i'll learn from that
even in adjacent industries does this
include that
i think i mean so that to me is
competitiveness and i'm a very
competitive person so i think there's a
there's a time and place for that i
think gaming does
facilitate that i think the apprentice
model um
you know when i'm let's say i'm
mentoring someone or let's say i have a
mentor
the mentor is very much still learning
from me it's it kind of goes both ways
and the same thing is with
my mentoring people too it's i still
have that apprentice mentality
because i'm getting different
perspective and i'm probably out of
touch with a lot of things that are now
new
man so powerful level eight is alchemy
what does that even mean
yeah so alchemy is so i used to play uh
you know world of warcraft and everquest
and used to there's some some certain
classes that can create stuff from thin
air right
and um you know when i think about
alchemy it's
kind of the work that we're doing with
uh marketing or sales
you're kind of creating stuff from from
thin air right it's the magic of being
able to pull people to you so when you
think about your youtube channel sean
you're pulling a lot of people to you
and then you're actually able to
generate a sale it's just like
it's magic to me right you're you're
doing it in real life so i think
there's a it's very important to
understand both sales and marketing
um it doesn't matter if you are in any
role at all because every single day
you're selling yourself
like when we when you go out to
somewhere you're talking to your team
members you have to sell the vision
right or if you're talking to a prospect
you got to sell that as well but if you
want to bring people in
it's it's easier to market and you have
to play the long game which is um
you know put out content uh get better
at the content and then just think for
the long term right compound over time
and eventually you'll get there and is
alchemy it is like the combination
of different materials if you were to
talk about doing alchemy with a sword is
that accurate or am i wrong there yeah
no that that's right
so in a way it's also kind of like to
really have an edge
in 2021 and beyond you you maybe need to
combine different things there's a
fascinating book called range
which actually proposed that
generalists will actually succeed over
specialists
in the new world because you'd think
that even maybe robots and ai
can take over a very specific task but
when you're a generalist
in a way if you're pulling in maybe pop
culture
meets understanding of design meets
understanding of copywriting
meets understanding of business and your
end object objective
meets understanding the customer whoever
understands the customer or the viewer
best wins
you're you need to do alchemy with all
those things to potentially create
a youtube video a sales funnel a product
and this is kind of like the modern
skill set of
combining these different disciplines
yes yeah i mean it's
i think this is really important too
it's very hard to find people in life
that are able to connect the dots well
so
you know if you're a t-shaped let's say
uh talking about a marketer right if
you're a t-shaped marketer let's say you
go deep on seo but you understand the
other nuances pretty well
you're able to connect the dots maybe if
i do well in seo over here
i can do something with youtube and then
you know one plus one equals four right
just like the example i gave earlier
um or you know you can talk about um
being able to uh combine i don't know
let's say your social media prowess
with um let's say a customer data
platform whatever you just combine the
different things that's my main point
yeah that's amazing um well i'm so
excited for this book there's another
one
um level 13 thievery
what an interesting chapter name and way
to level up so what do you mean by
thievery yeah you know um i think it was
steve jobs that said everything in life
is a remix
and i remember one of the i won a
championship when i was 13 years old and
basically this is called a best of the
best right and for for my my class i was
playing a druid right so that was one of
my classes
and um you know the character that i
played and um whoever won would get the
championship you would be
you know known to everyone on the server
right in the preliminaries i was getting
dominated by everybody
i was inferior in terms of strength and
fears in terms of inferior in terms of
equipment
um until we got to the real matches and
because i got lucky with the the timing
i saw one person that was really good
and i just i was like oh
this person's moving around differently
this place is this person is playing
differently
and then i i i was like oh i think i can
do better than that and because i played
a lot of quake before i played a lot of
um
half-life you know counter-strike
whatever and so
that person was just strafing around
when they were fighting right the other
people just kind of standing still and
fighting
so i was like okay i'll just copy that
and because i copy that person i end up
winning the championship but then
that that moment i was like oh you know
what all i need to do is is
ethically copy people copy things that
make sense and take it in for myself and
just mold it into my own right and so a
lot of the things that you see
taking this into the business world
right now a lot of people are
um let's see you have you have okay you
start with aws
right and everyone's like oh google's
like i want to do one too microsoft
let's do azure right everyone's copying
amazon um
and you everyone can say you know
everyone wants to be original and all
that but at the end of the day
we're all very much just kind of you
know iterating on the shoulders of
giants right so my point here is that
when i when i use the word thievery you
can steal ethically right because
again there's a lot of inspiration from
around you um just
just steal ethically just make sure you
give credit where it's due
man that's one of my favorite tips and i
remember steve jobs i saw a little video
clip
of him quoting pablo pagasso that
good artists copy great artist steele
and he said we've never been afraid
of taking the best ideas and i think
what's exciting there's the great book
still like an artist
um the of taking the best ideas but
where it really gets interesting is when
you're pulling maybe from outside of
your industry and into your industry a
friend of mine
chalene johnson um is one of she holds
world records for the most
fitness dvds sold she's you know the
inventor of piyo and turbo jam and turbo
kick
and back in the day um fitness workout
dvds that you would order on an
infomercial
were very like cut and dry kind of they
were very professional
and she was watching tv and she saw
there was like
bloopers in certain videos or america's
funniest home videos
and she just thought well what if i put
more of my personality but what if we
did like
we were way less serious what if we're
doing the serious workout
but we just put bloopers in it that
doesn't seem revolutionary today
but at the time she saw an idea
somewhere else combined it
with her industry and her niche and
really broke through with people like
man this is much more real
and much more relatable and so i think
it's kind of fascinating to potentially
use ethical thievery by being maybe
exposed to
even other industries or even channels
outside of your niche or
other youtube channels and think about
elements that you can combine and
you set it it becomes a remix some of
our favorite songs
are a classic beat with the new bass
line with some new lyrics and some
different vocals
and so there's the old and the new kind
of put together and it ultimately
becomes new
when that is presented to the public and
it could be the very thing that helps
someone break through in 2021.
talking about combining so totally right
if you start with an apprentice mindset
you're going to be learning a lot of
things and then that's going to give you
ideas and then you're going to be able
to ethically steal the ones that make
sense
according to what you're doing man
that's amazing so
um a lot of people listening you know
some people are more established this
has been some
very practical things we can apply uh
you got to pick up the book leveling up
it's out on amazon people can get it
everywhere yeah yep um and so
check out the book eric sue leveling up
but if someone's just starting
because we have got some people in our
community right that are kind of just
getting into the game
man life's hit them potentially like a
freight train
their industry's been disrupted they
find themselves
furloughed or working from home they're
trying to reinvent they maybe want to
create a business from home and build a
life on their own terms so that
they can spend more time with their kids
or have more freedom and
um you know i'm not sure how long you've
been in this and maybe you could share a
little bit of your story but i think
i've been trying to level up learn
hustle on youtube
build my side hustle build a business
for over a decade now
focused for the last five years and it
can be kind of overwhelming in today's
landscape to think about being
at that beginner stage in 2021 what's
some advice
when maybe you just take us a little bit
back to your journey
of the daunting thought
of man how am i gonna do this how am i
gonna break through everybody else's
i'm comparing my beginning to other
people's middle and i i feel like i
don't even want to start what's some
advice you've learned
for new entrepreneurs yeah i think i
mean there's there's a lot of um cliches
here right
we talk about fail forward my favorite
quote is from uh winston
churchill if you're going through hell
keep going i think
also reframing um so you know the title
of this is think right i think people
need to rethink
how the how they approach pain i think
physical pain
yes you don't want too much of that
right but
mental pain i mean that's kind of the
prerequisite to get to the next level
you're going to have to go through
certain levels of pain to reach the next
level that's how you keep leveling up
um and so understanding that you know
most people that have achieved obviously
the vast majority of people that have
achieved success have gone through a lot
of pain to get there
um that's the ticket and i think
you know i have a chapter in in the book
um towards the end
talking about the wealth ladder which is
from the the ceo of convertkit
i think it's a great concept the whole
idea here is that you know you go to
school
and then the whole idea after that is
you build great habits and leveling up
is certainly about getting the right
power-ups the right habits
and then afterwards maybe you start
working somewhere let's say you don't
have a job anymore
maybe the next step is maybe you can
freelance for free right that's the
easiest thing you can do with
not a lot of cost to get going that's
why even though i hate the traditional
agency model i think it's a beautiful
way to say hey look
i don't have any experience right now
i'm just going to reach out to to people
i want to work with
and then a certain amount are going to
say yes and then maybe a month later
after they like the work
you know maybe they i have them as
clients right i think consulting is
never going to go away
and then once you get to a certain level
you can start to think about hiring
people you can start to think about
building an agency
and if you want to take it to the next
level you can reinvest those cash flows
go build a product
go build a network effects business if
you want or go build a spacex right
but the whole idea here is you're also
leveling up the cash flows and you're
leveling up the business model
because you know this this type of thing
sure you can survive
by um by doing consulting but if you
want to thrive maybe you take it to an
agency model but if you truly want to
grow beyond that
you're probably gonna have to to think
about where else you want to invest the
money so
that's what i would say the other
alternative is you can do drop shipping
with e-commerce you know collect the
smaller margin
and then if you want to take it one
level higher then you can start to hold
inventory and then you could have a
higher margin
and then you could take it one level
further beyond that you can just keep
leveling up there's just different
stages for different businesses
eric sue he's dropping the leveling up
strategies the new book is out now and
you want to uh go grab that
and um thank you eric you also got to
check out his podcast
the marketing school um what's the other
podcast
leveling up leveling up podcast and
um i love i just want to acknowledge you
and appreciate you adding value to our
community today
um everything i've learned from you and
your community
um the event we got to do together was
uh was super fun and just the way you
think
man iron sharpens iron and being around
you always makes me think bigger
really eric not to be cliche but it
levels
me up so i appreciate you i'm excited
about this book
and uh uh with as much uncertainty as
there is in 2021
i think when we stay connected to good
people like you and we stay on kind of
the cutting edge of what's happening we
can continue to have an
edge in marketing and business
for sure thanks for having me really
appreciate it and yeah i hope to hope to
catch up
in real life soon wow i hope that you
were taking notes during that podcast
because eric is on another level when it
comes to understanding
how to level up yourself and your
business
he's such a dynamic entrepreneur who
really has the pulse
on what's happening i don't know about
you but i have just discovered clubhouse
like you said at the beginning
and i am obsessed with being on there
hearing and listening into the
conversation so
not that i that you need to jump out
right now and start a brand new social
media platform for your youtube channel
but it's just good for us to every now
and then come up and actually look at
what's happening what's the landscape
and as eric said audio is the up and
coming so just be thinking about
how can you apply this to your youtube
channel how can you go deeper with your
own community or
how can you tap into other markets who
need
what you have on youtube this is just
for us as
content creators to be aware of i want
you to stay focused and locked on
growing your youtube
channel this year but also remember that
as you level yourself up
as you level your business up as you
outsource and as you grow your team
that these are things to be thinking
about when it comes to how to get the
information that you have out
to your audience and if you are really
in those beginning stages of trying to
figure out how to crush it on youtube
first before you go to those other
platforms then i want to encourage you
that after you're done listening to this
podcast
that you head over to our free one hour
youtube
masterclass you can get all the details
right now
at thinkmasterclass.com this is a one
hour class that's going to share with
you the three secrets to youtube success
how to win on youtube this year and what
to avoid
as a content creator i know there is so
much to learn when it comes to youtube
and we've distilled a decade's worth of
information
into one hour for you to be able to go
further faster on youtube so make sure
that if you've not checked out that free
master class that that is your next step
here after the podcast if you are loving
this podcast i want to encourage you
also to
go and rate and review the podcast on
itunes if you're listening to this
podcast right now on itunes
then please make sure before you leave
that you leave and rate and
that you don't leave that you rate and
review this podcast
if you're listening on other podcasting
platforms or over on youtube
then grab your phone pull up the itunes
app and
rate and review today's podcast this not
only just helps us
get to more creators but it also lets us
see who's in our community
and it allows us to shout you out and
today's shout out goes to
savvy ecoqueen and she wrote five
stars thank you so much for rating us as
five stars
she says i love how sean brings god into
every episode
it helps keep me grounded as i grow in
my mission
i try to only follow leaders who can do
just
this he's funny and energetic and not
many can say
and i'm sorry and not many can show that
through
a podcast well hey savvy eco queen thank
you so much for
hearing our heart for knowing that we
really are on mission to help you
grow on youtube but that we also aren't
afraid to share who we are
you know in a previous episode sean
really talked about being your authentic
self
and i'm so grateful that you saw that
for us that meant that
family is important that our faith is
important and that our community and our
friends are
so important just like you so thank you
so much for leaving that review
and for letting us know that you can see
sean's energetic
and entertaining that's a joke if you've
not seen his first video
through the microphone here on the
podcast so thank you for rating and
reviewing and i can't wait to read
all the other reviews on the podcast
well thank you so much for your time and
for being here to listen to today's
episode make sure that you are
subscribed so that you get
locked into the next episode it is a no
miss
so make sure that you are ready for that
episode with your pen
and your paper and you're ready to take
notes because shawn is delivering some
fire for our next episode thanks again
for being here and we'll catch you
in the next podcast
[Music]
you